primero fue el Sí en el senado francés y
luego el gobierno impidió el debate en
la asamblea nacional al inicio de la
sesión cuando ya se conocía la decisión
Del ejecutivo tras la filtración a un
medio de comunicación los diputados de
la oposición empezaron a entonar la
marsellesa
[Aplausos]
la primera ministra Elizabeth born
finalmente invocó el artículo 49-3 de la
Constitución para dar luz verde a la
reforma pensional del gobierno de Manuel
macrón
no podemos jugarnos el futuro de
nuestras pensiones esta reforma es
necesaria por lo tanto sobre la base del
artículo 49 párrafo tres de la
Constitución comprometo la
responsabilidad de mi gobierno sobre el
conjunto del proyecto de ley de la
Reforma de seguridad Social para 2023
modificado por la enmienda de
coordinación comunicada a la asamblea
nacional
Pero qué es este artículo Y por qué le
da esta potestad al gobierno el Primer
Ministro podrá previa deliberación del
Consejo de ministros comprometer la
responsabilidad del gobierno ante la
asamblea nacional en la votación de un
proyecto de ley de finanzas o de
financiación de la seguridad social en
este caso el proyecto de ley se
considerará adoptado A menos que se
apruebe una moción de censura
en las 24 horas siguientes el Primer
Ministro podrá además recurrir a este
procedimiento para otro proyecto o
proposición de ley por periodo de
sesiones de este modo al menos diez
partes del total de la asamblea nacional
deben ponerse de acuerdo para presentar
una moción de censura en las 24 horas
posteriores a la aplicación del artículo
una moción que luego debe ser ratificada
por la mayoría absoluta del parlamento
para hacer caer al gobierno este jueves
El Ejecutivo marcó otro hito ya que es
la vez número 100 que se aplica el 49-3
en la quinta República concretamente
Elizabeth born es la segunda jefa de
gobierno que más veces lo ha puesto en
marcha 11
ahora la asamblea y las calles tendrán
que dar su palabra sobre el
controvertido proyecto de ley que
pretende aumentar la edad de jubilación
de los 62 a los 64 años y que ha
movilizado a millones de personas contra
la propuesta desde hace semanas